last month the far left school board in
loudoun county virginia passed one of
the most far-reaching and radical trans
policies in the country under the new
rules
male students who identify as female
will be able to use female restrooms in
locker rooms of course females who
identify as males will be able to do the
reverse but you notice that there are
never as many girls
wanting to access the boys locker room
as there are boys wanting to access the
girls locker room
same for sports teams a strange
coincidence isn't it but the policy goes
beyond sports teams and locker rooms it
also requires teachers to use the
preferred pronouns of their students
now magnanimously teachers will not be
punished if they have an unintentional
slip and accidentally utter an incorrect
read correct pronoun but any teacher who
intentionally and with malice a
forethought dares to use proper grammar
in their classroom will be in violation
and you know suffer the so far vaguely
outlined consequences
this part of the policy is particularly
odious i mean it's all odious but this
presents special complications because
gender-confused kids
can quite literally change their
pronouns on a daily or hourly basis
that's part of what it means to be fluid
like i mean it doesn't really mean
anything to be fluid but if it means
anything uh it means that it can change
by the second maybe
and they might invent new pronouns on
the spot they might demand that their
teachers speak an absolute gibberish
and the teacher will be expected to
remember which gibberish and then change
to different gibberish if they're
instructed to do so
all in all teachers are being made to
affirm falsehoods to speak untruths to
babble incoherently to reject the rules
of grammar and the english language and
ultimately to abandon their role as
educator in favor of becoming high
priests of the leftist religion
now many teachers in the county and
across the country
seem more than happy to fill this role
we're already filling it many of them
but some have resigned in protest or
filed lawsuits to challenge the new
rules one teacher tanner cross
an elementary physical education
instructor in the district was fired
after speaking out against the policy
during a meeting a school board meeting
a few months ago let's listen to his
remarks again because they were it's
very brief but but powerful and true
here he is
my name is tanner cross and i'm speaking
out of love for those who suffer with
gender dysphoria 60 minutes this past
sunday interviewed over 30 young people
who transitioned but they felt that
astray because lack of pushback or how
easy it was to make physical changes to
their bodies in just three months they
are now de-transitioning it's not my
intention to hurt anyone but there are
certain truths that we must face when
ready we condemn school policies like 80
40 and 80 35 because it will damage
children defy defile the holy image of
god i love all of my students but i will
never lie to them regardless of the
consequences i'm a teacher but i serve
god first and i will not affirm that a
biological boy can be a girl and vice
versa because it's against my religion
it's lying to a child it's abuse to a
child and it's sinning against our god
now cross was as i said fired for that
he was fired for disagreeing with the
school board
that they decided is is a an offense
worthy of termination
fortunately a judge stepped in and
reinstated across to his position
clarifying that school boards cannot in
fact fire teachers for disagreeing with
them it's public comments
you're supposed to give up stand up
there and give your opinion
and they fired him for giving an opinion
they don't like
tanner is
one teacher taking a brave stance
against sinister lunacy
there are others and there are parents
too but they're outnumbered and so i
would like to help change that that's
why i will personally be coming to
loudoun county virginia on september
28th which is the date of their next
school board meeting to help lead a
rally against all of this madness the
rally will be at 5 pm on september 28th
at 21 000 education court in ashburn
now some of us will also try to speak
during the meeting itself but the board
has changed the rules in recent months
to make it harder to do that they won't
allow crowds inside the building during
public comments they can set the time
limit for public comments down to one
minute if they decide
uh these are obviously tactics meant to
mute voices of dissent which is why i
want to show up with hundreds and
hundreds of those voices and set up shop
right outside the building
i'm asking anyone in the vicinity to
come and make your voice heard as well
now i can tell you from my part that
you know i don't want to just hang out
on the sidelines and complain into a
camera anymore i mean i'm still going to
complain to the camera but
my efforts will will go beyond that
um those who
push evil and insanity must be
confronted directly in person
schools that harm children have to be
confronted
that we can all sit around lamenting the
disintegration of our culture saying oh
man isn't it too bad that they're
mutilating the minds and souls and
bodies of a generation of children gee
what a shame
oh well let's see what else is on tv
or we can get up get out and do
something about it
there's power in numbers but those
numbers have to be mobilized and brought
together in one place
numbers don't mean anything all this
stuff about being a silent majority
i hate that phrase
silent majority i don't think it's true
i don't know if it's true i doubt that
it's true i almost hope that it isn't
because shame on us if we're in the
majority still
and silent
doesn't mean anything it's not anything
to be proud of
we're the majority and we're too afraid
to say anything yay go us
numbers don't mean anything if we are
silent and fractured and disorganized
and too afraid to speak above a whisper
content to voice our disapproval through
you know sad-faced emojis on social
media
now
i announced this rally on twitter a
couple days ago and already i've heard
from the opposition in loudoun county
they are to say the least not happy that
we're coming
more than one person has threatened
violence against me
these are people who are so determined
to rob young girls of their privacy and
their identity that they will threaten
to assault or kill you if you try to
prevent it
they believe so strongly that boys
should be in the girl's bathroom that
they will they say commit violent
felonies to ensure that it happens
now that that makes me afraid
not for myself i'm still coming you're
not going to scare me away but for the
kids whose minds and bodies these
slobbering maniacs
these these
predator freaks are trying to destroy
another criticism i've heard is that i'm
not from loudoun county
i'm an outside agitator they say this is
none of my business
well even if that's true
i'm making it my business
protecting children is everybody's
business opposing child abuse is
everybody's business
i don't care where kids are being harmed
doesn't make any it doesn't become any
less outrageous or any less of a concern
if it's happening in a different zip
code
your zip code is different go away and
let us brainwash these kids in peace
sorry i don't find that argument
terribly compelling and besides outside
forces national advocacy groups
hollywood media politicians routinely
inject themselves into these issues to
ensure that schools and towns and states
are run as they prefer
i can guarantee that if a school board
passed a rule forbidding biological
males from entering the female restroom
hollywood celebrities and the human
rights campaign and cnn and all the rest
of them would be chiming in on the issue
calling for boycotts everything else
and none of the people telling me to
butt out and mind my business would be
saying the same to them
so this is a one-way street when they
need reinforcements from national
figures they're not shy about going out
and getting them
but if the other side does the same
suddenly they become firm proponents of
the principles of subsidiarity
i'm not going to abide by rules that
change depending on whose side they
benefit
not gonna happen
so complain all you want tell me i don't
belong tell me this is not my concern
threaten to kill me i'm still gonna be
there
one other point uh tanner cross in his
brief but uh but but really great speech
was correct that this is a religious
rights issue
um
also it's also correct to argue as as i
just have that this is a privacy and
safety issue
okay all of that is true
and those are the those seem to be the
main
points that that that we on this side
the sane side
uh make that you know this religious
liberty
it it infringes on privacy
of girls and locker rooms and it's also
unsafe that's all true those are all
good points
but this is also we have to keep
insisting
something bigger and broader than that
more than anything else
more important
than religious rights
or even safety
is truth
this is about truth
truth is the most important thing truth
is more important than liberty it's more
important than than life itself there
could be no liberty without truth there
could be no life at least not a life
worth living without truth
all of the good things in life love
freedom you name it all of it they're
all predicated on truth
they all exist within truth the trans
agenda is more than anything
an attack on truth it is an attempt to
build a society which fundamentally
rejects and does not recognize truth
they want us all to live outside of
truth
they want our kids to be educated in
lies
in darkness not in truth not in light
that's the battle we're fighting first
and foremost
and it will certainly take more than a
rally at a school board to win that
fight but you have to start something
and so i hope you'll join us
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated